there's one thing that makes me really
angry but no one dislikes cheaters as
much as every games thank you at the
games for your noble deeds you may have
heard the story epic games is suing a
14-year old for cheating in fortnight
and his mother is fighting back
epic games this is epic games and this
is haters sue you I'm gonna sue you
suing you left or right
[Laughter]
that's great but there's epic games is
suing this 14 are all in all but do they
know have they confirmed if it's Clara
or not wait what the [ __ ] Clara hold on
Clara give me one second
Clara let me just message this girl give
me one second why the [ __ ] is this on my
computer right now where is this how do
I close this you'll rock I need some
help because I don't know what I'm
looking at right now what the [ __ ] is
that
hello
I bet it was Clara that's enough sneaky
sneaky snake that sneaky snake Clara
always coming in with her cheese
now if you haven't played for tonight
it's a battle royale type of game good
old fun and
people like to cheat in it TEM PZ ghost
yeah dude yo he just stopped and meted
and literally now there's a fight right
in front of him that he there's no
vision of whatsoever yep
instant headshot again and he just shot
at somebody that you can even see yep
another one another one gasps he's a
hundred percent [ __ ] cheating oh my
god I'm [ __ ] recording this [ __ ] is
that Claire that's class I think that's
Claire now don't get me wrong I I don't
understand why you would cheat and
that's not me making some I don't
understand how someone could possibly
cheat in the game it's more like how fun
is it to just watch the computer play
the game for you like you're not playing
the game if you're cheating in a
first-person shooter and you're being an
[ __ ] okay you're being an ass to stop
cheating that's right
family nice guy PewDiePie telling you
here right as it is now don't cheat in
video games
cheating is a huge problem for fortnight
and so what does epic games to create a
fortnight do they make a statement they
made a statement on their website saying
that they're gonna strike down on these
cheaters they're gonna they're gonna
they're gonna get them they didn't say
how though they said we don't want to
give too many clues about what we're
doing but we're going to roll out tools
at the games just go and like
can I give too many clues how we're
gonna stop these cheaters but have some
ideas about a week later it comes out
that ethics suits for nine cheaters for
copyright infringement it seems a bit
weird to sue someone cheating for
copyright infringement like that's how
they strike down on them but apparently
I might be wrong I don't really
understand the whole coding bit but
they're changing the coding which they
don't own the copyright to and they're
not allowed to do that
so that's copyright infringement I don't
I don't how do you mod then what what's
modding then it's modding illegal in
their legal document though they they
wrote cheats give a cheater power to do
or see things that other players cannot
for instance a cheat might enable a
cheater to see through solid objects
teleport or make moves other players
cannot such as a spin followed by an
instant headshot to another player I
never thought I'd see a 360 no-scope
being described in legal terms well done
nearly any online game will lose players
if it gets infested by cheaters it's
statistically proven every time that
cheaters drive players away and for good
reasons no one likes to play with the
cheater it's it's not fun their approach
to this was to sue these players to stop
people from cheating people are saying
they're making an example out of these
people both defendants face up 250,000
statutory damages for copyright
infringement now I've seen arguments on
both side of this saying this is
ridiculous even my game publisher
standards banned the offenders and move
on if your game is easily broken it's on
you but then I have the other side of
people saying good you know we don't
like cheaters they're ruining the game
I'm glad they are striking down on them
it's a very divided topic and that's
what we discussed here on the PewDiePie
channel the thing though that this
comment isn't taken into account is that
forty-ninth is a free-to-play game you
can't just ban the player they're just
gonna make a new an account and that's
what was happening with one of the
cheaters is that they made new accounts
over and over and over and that's why
they finally decided okay we need to
stop these guys now then it came out
through a document sent by the mother of
one of the cheaters that he is
fourteen-year-old there was a plea sent
to the judge from the mother who people
speculate as a lawyer and she makes a
pretty good case against epic games
actually she basically states that
Fortnight needs a legal parents consent
for minors and that she never gave this
consent epic games also claimed that
they lost profit because of cheaters and
that they are to blame for that but
she's saying there's no way you can
actually prove that she says that it's
wrong for them to go against the players
instead of the websites distributing the
cheats and she's also pointing out that
her son's name publicly was May was made
public and that's against Delaware laws
so she makes a pretty good point I
thought that that so you might think
okay well I fit games you know they
overreacted they $150,000 that's just
stupid okay it's a fourteen-year-old kid
but you go to the fourteen-year-old its
Channel and it has quality quality
content such as GTA V modding trolling
feat rapist quality just the finest
there's him cheating in GTA 5 he's not
even back now are you Jack going alright
yeah we officially prove that you're the
hacker man how to mod called blackops on
Xbox yeah I would be dumb storage and
then a hover
all right now once you boot up the issue
you guys also got the new authors and he
also made a response video to the
lawsuit which is it's hard to empathize
with the guy yo what's going on guys sky
it would be here in this video guys this
is an ahmadi video so shouldn't be
talking about my a lawsuit with epic
games so yeah we'll see you started
alright so what happened was I was
basically cheating and the game for and
I'm pretty sure all of you know this
really good that he just admitted it
well done
you know I downloaded a sheet from the
internet unknown she taught me he
promotes the cheating website where for
no cheats are [ __ ] everywhere you can
get them from any place anytime anywhere
now in this lawsuit at the games is
basically saying that I coded a cheat
and I was selling it and I admitted to
me making the cheat which I never made
that she I never coded the cheat I never
sold the cheat it was free to public you
could actually get it on under G stop me
if you guys know that website is it's
basically just downloading hacks it's a
free hack you can get it from anywhere
so basically he was streaming himself
cheating showing that he was cheating
telling players where to download the
cheat and how they can cheat as well
pretty scumbag thing to do
Epic's response to this was basically I
think it's not okay with ongoing
cheating or copyright infringement from
anyone at any age I don't really
understand how its copyright
infringement feel free to educate me on
that there was another legal document
filed from Epic Games where they quote
the cheaters saying new method is
exposed epic eat my ass defendant posted
in
defendant posted his circumvention
method to the cheat providers discussion
channel so that other cheaters could use
it and bragged now method is exposed
epic feat my ass also one of the other
cheaters is a moderator and member of
addicted cheats dotnet so it doesn't
look great for the kid it really doesn't
I don't think he deserves it one I think
when you're 14 you do a lot of dumb [ __ ]
and downloading it cheat and having your
parents having to pay on in fifty
thousand dollars that doesn't really
seem fair
to me even if you want to set an example
I cheated when I was a kid at games I
cheated in tibia where basically the
game would play itself but that felt
like I'm cheating the the game not other
players you could argue that it was but
it's different to me in a first-person
game cuz you're ruining the game for
cheating it I don't understand why you
would but kids like to do it but I can't
say that I don't understand why kids
don't do it kids are stupid
I think epic is doing the right thing to
strike down on cheaters I absolutely do
but at the same time I don't think this
is gonna stop cheaters strike down on
the websites distributing the cheats
focus on having counter measurement to
the cheats I'm sure they've already
working on that but they own the engine
it shouldn't be impossible to figure
some system out there's always gonna be
cheaters but this seems like a whole
mess to me and the kind of case where
just everyone loses the kids parents are
gonna lose money and time and effort and
epic games are gonna lose some of their
PR at the end of the day no one likes a
cheater I don't like cheaters either
don't cheat because cheating is bad you
heard it here first what do you think
leave a comment down below who is right
epic games 14 year old kid let me know
in the comments and as always don't
cheat because you know just don't do it
leave a like